[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we host webinars every
Tuesday my name is Paul young and today
we'll be talking about power innovation
for SCP with Google cloud you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and
today we have Googlers se peers and
customers on standby to answer them so
ask away
so let's get started ask us oh yeah and
that go-to-market director for a CBA
Google cloud and you'll hear plenty for
me so let's move on to the people that
matter
next to me is Isabel Petzl global vice
president of ICP cloud platform
go-to-market how do you even fit down a
business card I wouldn't ask we'll just
move on from there extra-wide business
cards for your subtitles subject of the
day first of all is they see being
Google Cloud partnership especially
around SME cloud platform but in general
too secondly we have a customer
perspective with Metro just great axel
cooks from Metro we'll be talking about
their deployment and this is the
criteria and how they're doing just
fantastic content and then lastly we'll
have a conversation about running SUV on
Google Cloud and the things we're doing
to make google clothes the best place
possible to run a CP and at the end of
that hopefully we'll have time to fit in
some questions and answers as well so
all that said let's get started with the
topic one welcome Isabel thank you Paul
so you want to introduce yourself to the
people watching I run the global centers
of expertise for s AP cloud platform
that's why the name is so long so I work
a lot with customers around the globe
and in helping them in their transition
their core enterprise application into
the cloud great I think you've come
along and you you're a long time SUV
person right 60 plus you're still
running strong
so what's top of mind what's the
challenge is that XE be customers have
right so what customers are really
challenged about today is finally
different then what happened in the last
few decades and what s ap traditionally
was focused on really about
standardizing optimizing core business
processes but today customers are really
forced to innovate and differentiate
themselves with disruptive business
models with complete new
customer experiences also giving
employees more purpose in their work
that will they leverage a lot of
technologies and data to really solve
those challenges and what we see in the
most successful company is what they are
doing they are adopting new technologies
and leveraging data very quickly and
that is what is delivering really
game-changing outcomes for them because
first they achieve a step change in
productivity by applying technologies
like machine learning like artificial
intelligence to those core business
processes to automate them to make them
more efficient second they also really
find the customer experience because
it's not only about any more responding
to customer needs
it is about predicting what customers
want and create that satisfaction before
the customers even know it and third
it's really about transforming their
employee engagement because employees
one of my have more purpose from work
they automate certain tasks so Empress
can really focus on higher level value
adding activities and tasks to really
move the company forward and that is
what we really talk about and what we
mean with intelligent enterprises
because customers today are hungry for
innovation to differentiate himself
right
I heard the intelligent enterprise
conversation a lot and I think that's a
really powerful way to explain it right
it's it's not just about analytics or
thing it is about that complete package
for the best very cool so what does you
be doing to deliver against those
challenges so I said customers are
really forced to to differentiate but
they want to build that innovation on a
solid trusted environment that on the
one hand side gives them the flexibility
but at the other hand side still has
that robustness and security to run
their core applications because that is
what customers love and trust about si P
running that that solid core and that is
where also si P has that process
heritage but now customers really want
to build new functionality on top of
those core processes to really
differentiate themselves look what
happened last week with cyber monday
where everyone went crazy here in the US
shopping were retailers actually
launched a very specific set
of functionality on their digital
platforms to create a new customer
experience to launch specific promotions
to engage differently with with
customers to boost up sales you don't
want to build those extensions that only
are there for a week or two into your
core business applications you want to
build them side-by-side on a platform
also utilizing latest technologies like
machine learning and so on to create
that experience and that is what sa P
both delivers on the one hand side solid
packaged applications for the core
business processes and a platform to
deliver and build those innovations on
top and everything in a single
environment cool so I I spent a long
time as a customer of s CP actually
running HP systems I found long time
with s CP I'll tell you the the point
where I came over to Google Cloud the
thing that amazed me was they I think
day three I walked in a room where there
were 20 engineers working on a single
joint project right amazing alignment
and investment between Google and SCP to
deliver something that's much more than
just hey you can run a CPU on Google
Cloud Hardware right so do you want to
talk quickly in your perspective on how
Google Cloud and SCP are working
together to take this far beyond just
hate another place you can run a CP in
the cloud absolutely I think the
partnership between Google is
fundamental in a game-changer because
together we are helping our customers in
their mission to succeed in the digital
transformation because I think there are
two fundamental things that the teams
have delivered first they really created
as I just said a fantastic place to run
s ap applications on top of Google Cloud
but really optimizing s ap ABS to run on
Google cloud but also optimize Google
Cloud to run s ap apps so those
engineering initiatives are happening on
both sides for the maximum of efficiency
and scale so look what we've done with
the virtual machines for Hana starting
with a few terabyte and now you can
deploy a 16 18 terabytes at the snap of
a finger so so that was really the one
piece to create the best place to run s
ap applications but what is even more
game-changing as we spoke before
customers want to build new
functionality they want to use latest to
nology and that is why that move having
s ap cloud platform run on Google cloud
was a fundamental game changer because
now customers can consume cutting-edge
technologies from Google p8 machine
learning be it tensor flow models and
really apply and infuse them into the
four processes of SA P in building those
differentiating innovations right out of
the box so we do all the plumbing for
them they can really focus on building
the innovation and that is what really
builds those intelligent enterprises
securely cool if you fall through as
well I think this is Bella part where
Google fits in the world is if you look
at the we're also a provider of data
sets right I'm doing stuff just in cloud
for marketing where we have the live
analysis of what customers advertising
is running how people are responding to
it right the ability did to through
cloud platform join that through and
just power and a level of granularity
and eye level the detail in the level of
execution is just never before it right
that's that's much much more than just a
place to run ICP in the cloud very cool
so your favorite subject cloud platform
obviously fits into this give us the
drillin how does co platform bind all of
this together
absolutely platform is almost the clue
that's the centerpiece of because
customers really on the one hand side
they need those business services they
need those processes and beneath the
innovation or the infrastructure
technology services from from from
Google cloud to really extend their core
processes in the s AP applications with
those technologies and really combine as
it just said combine transactional data
with other sources come from Google from
wherever in the world to really change
the customer experience and really
deliver those disruptive business models
but they want to do that on a platform
in parallel to their core system so
cloud platform almost becomes the bridge
between their packaged apps and their
innovation platform the bridge between
on-premise and cloud application because
it's a stepwise move because customers
are moving massive enterprise workloads
into the cloud so and they want to do
that at their own pace and that is
exactly what SME cloud platform gives
them it's really the innovation layer
in the cloud to build intelligent
enterprise applications and and and and
that is what what is really the game
changer in that partnership that now
ASAP cloud platform as the platform as a
service offering from s AP combined with
the latest technologies from Google to
extend those core business processes
while still keeping the integrity while
customers build those those innovations
in this platform now runs on Google
cloud so that's a game changer for our
customers to build innovation it's a
really big conversation I mean this is
it's a it's fascinating actually
recently have we seen that huge uptick
in demand where as customers start
applying the rest for journeys and start
to come bring us or over it's not just
hey you know lift and shift right it's
not just pick it up and drop it that you
you want to improve you want to enhance
they want to do more and you know them
so you unlock that right and again the
objective is to make it run here
hopefully better than anywhere exactly
that so to that subject what happens
then so so customer comes here they have
ICP running inside Google Cloud they
have Google earnest access they have
cloud platform what does that do to
unlock the intelligent for that you need
to look at how s ap delivers innovation
or how we deliver innovation to our
customers on the one hand side in the
digital core we update that once twice a
year and our cloud applications for the
different alibies we deliver innovations
about once a quarter so and any customer
gets that functionality so they do not
really differ in themselves through
those packaged applications so and that
is probably also not the speed that
customers really desire when they want
to build those competitive disruptive
new new business world models because
they really want to innovate repartee
they need iteration sometimes things
work don't work so they need that
flexibility on a platform to really
reinvent their enterprise processes at
their own pace and really build those
differentiating sets of functionality on
top of their packaged apps and that is
really key for the partnership where we
bring together to those customers
because we deliver that innovations on
two level on the one hand side on the
infrastructure level by bringing techno
is to run enterprise applications from
sa peon containers with kubernetes k
native bring them really to enterprise
readiness and scale and on the other
hand side on the service level where we
allow customers to seamlessly consume
infrastructure services from from google
be it machine learning be it artificial
intelligence natural language processing
and really infuse that into our core
business processes think about the we
just released there those event triggers
function as a service for our latest
digital chorus for hannah to give you an
example I'm German I love cars right and
I go now out of the Google parking lot
and I take a nice picture from whatever
car we are not making any promotions
here and post it on my Twitter feed
because it's a cool car then actually
the what the car companies are doing
today they are scanning the social feeds
using image recognition to detect their
cars who has posted what about that car
on the web and they realize who this guy
wants to is interests it or likes my car
why don't I send him an offer where he
can configure his car where he can
basically submit an order and ultimately
I submit an order then throughout the
production process which takes a few
weeks and is running of course on on
core solid s AP systems producing
hundreds and thousands of cars at scale
those function as a service now allow
you that an event gets triggered when
that car enters the painting facility
and then a picture is sent to the
customer showing exactly his car in the
production line when the seats get in
and so on so that keeps the customer
engaged through the entire process and
this is not happening or you should not
do that in your core applications
because you don't want to touch that you
have to produce those two hundred
thousand cars this is now what you can
really develop on the platform using
services image recognition and so on
from Google to really build that special
special functionality without disrupting
your core so it's no longer about it's a
pure outcomes and processes it is really
about redefining the innovation cycle in
your company by quickly building those
innovations on top of a stable core
I think it also ties in every with
bankers to the conversation you
mentioned community is a key native and
that's really cool but also if you look
at the that investment where we can add
virtual machines right so a conversation
that says hey I have an idea and I want
to develop that really quickly in cloud
platform I know I want to test it so in
history if you have a giant you have
about 18 terabyte you know production
system running inside Hana where you've
got to keep a spear you can terabyte box
around right or you're gonna try and run
out on top of of QA and how'd you manage
all of that stuff I suppose to our world
where you can literally provision that
server in 30 seconds take a replica of
production integrity be build the entire
test environment you need pay for it by
the second if it works off the
production if it doesn't work back to
revision right just again the
combination of SUV and cool cloud just
unlocks um you know potential that just
isn't everyone's dreamed of this no
one's been so far right about that point
where I could just spin up copies of
production run testing drop them again
unlocks just really the future which is
really cool I'd say so so wrapping it up
what a customers take away from this
what's the call to action here right
because customers to be clear they're
making really big bets moving into the
cloud causes a whole new set of
questions because especially in the
enterprise they're moving their holy
grail their core business applications
into the cloud and they're really
infusing cutting-edge technologies into
their core processes which is can be a
nightmare or customers are really scared
to move that move and that is exactly
why why PI customers need partners they
can trust
then you partners that understand the
enterprise and they need partners that
can grow with them and that's exactly
the reason for this partnership why I
say P and Google came came together
because only together we can make sure
to have our customers move with
confidence into the cloud to allow them
to rapidly innovate and experiment
without risk building those new
functionalities leveraging those new
cutting-edge technologies while still
running a stable core and that is what
customers want they want to innovate
fast they want to be agile they want to
build all of that on a trusted platform
to evolve their business and that is
exactly what we together can deliver
them I think it's really fascinated
recording for a partner recently where I
said you know if you look especially
right now the customers are looking at
over a desk for and doing everything
else the a lot of this is it's a
commitment almost like a marriage right
you're making a long-term commitment and
so you have to trust and you have to
believe in everyone in it right you have
to believe that it gets you you know
what you want in the end I think it's
again the the brand of se be the brand
of Google the what we deliver to our
customers combined this is something
quite remarkable especially in this
scenario really thank you for the time
hang around I know you're gonna sneak
off and answer some questions in the
community and come back later and we'll
take some life but we appreciate the
time thanks your time great great so
separately great for us to talk about
the theory let's make it real so what we
have at this point is some content from
Axl Coast at Metro so four weeks ago
Metro stood up at next London I think is
about four weeks the weeks all blend
together my travel schedule right now
and we recently axle or Metro stood up
the next London and talked about how
they're moving their ACP and environment
to Google cloud amazing project this
isn't just again a lift and shift there
are 100s UV systems he'll tell you
himself the intent to consolidate during
the 1s war system that's a pretty
significant effort and there's reasons
why they chose Google cloud to do that
and you'll go just the platform and I'll
let Axl
tell you what those are
paradox a cause for metronome metronome
at a tech company of Metro mater was one
of the biggest b2b wholesaler worldwide
we have business in 35 countries 150,000
colleagues and 21 million customers our
goal means Metro goal is very clear to
bring the food and hospitality sector on
a new level by providing digital
solutions for the business the
challenges are coming from different
kind of stay Cola internal as well
external if I have looked on first on
the internal stakeholder for example the
accounting departments they would like
to close their books much faster as they
are able to do it today
on the other side controlling would like
to get most like a real-time insight
into our figures to make the right
proposals for the management to make the
right decisions afterwards and then we
are coming to the external stakeholder
for example our investors they would
like to get a much better understanding
of our businesses and the most important
topic is here for sure our b2b hozier
customer they are asking for more and
more digital services for sure
most likely in the e-commerce area but
nevertheless they are also asking for
much more services in the finance area
here we already provide some services
like even worse to make this happen
we were searching for the right
infrastructure and the right earpiece
system we found them with SP for Hana
and Google cloud platform
[Music]
first of all I would like to mention
that we already have business on Google
cloud platform most likely in the
e-commerce I mentioned before this is a
important part of our omni-channel
strategy nevertheless we spoke with the
Google haa who are involved already in
the e-commerce area but also we
discussed this topic with our colleagues
by Google based on this we really
decided to make this smooth I really
would like to point out that from day
one on we were at a very good
partnership that means for me at least
we are equal partners we are open-minded
and we are very focused to make things
happen
for sure up front we had also a look on
the market to look for other
alternatives but nevertheless I really
would like to make the same decision
today once again
[Music]
first of all allow me to explain what
consultation here minds for metronome
this means we as a PA Google and
metronome joined forces to realize our
key objective to streamline our SFP
finance landscape from around 100 to one
system sound ambitions yes you are
completely right but nevertheless this
is our going to make the segment we will
using first Google cloud platform second
SFP for Hana finance as our core system
running on Google cloud platform C as a
peak cloud platform if we need any kind
of developments also running on Google
cloud what we can see so far it's really
working as planned and if you open such
boxes you get a real wow effect in your
teams why you see a lot of different
opportunities you can use in the cloud
services but stay focused otherwise it
can really happen that you cannot see
the wood for the trees
we use our objective and key result
process that means the odd outcome was a
clear action item plan based on this
everybody in the teams know exactly what
to be done we defined it so clear
because SP for Hana in combination with
Google cloud platform and as ap cloud
platform give us as I mentioned already
a lot of different opportunities but
coming back to our teams Keith success
is change management why keep in mind
everybody has to work in the future with
SP for Hana and the teams they are
working on a complete new infrastructure
and they see a lot of opportunities and
respect of cloud services this is at
least for us in the IT but as well in
the business a big challenge everybody
is highly engaged and everybody is
seeing a clear advantage of this journey
very clear go out and try it build up
your own environment on Google cloud
platform and as ap cloud platform define
your own user stories you would like to
start with I wish you good luck bye this
so thanks to Axel for the
the discussion really appreciate having
Metro as a customer really appreciate
them contributing to this and he
continues to contribute he's live in the
Q&A right now if you want to ask him
questions and please do I've always the
best input when I was a customer came
from other customers and today is no
exception so with that my task of the
day is to introduce you to why we think
running SVP in Google cloud is better
than anywhere else and what we're doing
in order to try and make it the best
place to run a CP in the cloud so I
start with one slide my my favorite
slide of them all the slide basically is
describing to you the SCP Hana virtual
machines we have available and that part
of the conversation where I say virtual
machine is the most important right
everybody else in this market is still
largely a bare-metal no one else has a
virtual machine server above 6 terabytes
that rude map says we will have virtual
machines of 12 and 18 terabytes in next
year and we already have in the light
green box that will come back to a 7
terabyte VM available to customers to
demonstrate that it's possible that
becomes really important in this
conversation because if you go back in
history from from launch of r3 there has
been a way that customers procure and
buy the equipment that they were on ASAP
on right back in the day there's a tool
called quick sizer that's still used
where the customers come through and has
they want to roll up project they have
to estimate for words what their largest
hour will be in the next three years so
let's say you're a retailer that's not
hard to guess that's you know probably
atm
Black Friday in 2022 at this point after
deployment
good luck however guessing what that
that the point what that sizing is right
and it ultimately is a guess there's a
point where you concise to a point but
then you have to ask them a growth you
have to estimate change in software and
so customers tend to buy a huge amount
of equipment in hope that three years
from now there are their size to fit and
if they are if they don't buy enough
they have a huge problem because they
basically have to refresh what they have
and buy again if the buy two little are
sorry if they bite
much then they've just wasted money and
no one wants to waste money and so the
answer to that is not to do that right
because we really can't predict the
future
thirty years from now is a long time
away and how are we gonna get to that
number predictably we're not
we never have it's always been a guess I
think the challenge for me is as we
migrated to the cloud and asked all
providers came online a lot of them just
replicated that hardware model directly
in the cloud so they came along and they
said you have to do a three-year sizing
you have to tell me how big you're gonna
be three years you'll have to say in a
three-year contract um that's not what
the college supposed to be about right
that's not how this is supposed to work
and so a Google Club we've approached a
CP radically differently we build our
own servers we build our own virtual
machines we build them from scratch and
we do that for a reason
and the reason is exactly this that you
fundamentally when you come to us I
don't need to know how big you're going
to be in three years because you don't
really know how big you're gonna be in
three years I just need to know how big
you are now you can deploy in that
equipment and then as you get bigger as
you grow as you change over time you
have the ability just to step up through
that rank because they're all
reconfigurable right well that does is
that allows me to take a lot of the risk
that exists in your current environment
in sizing and provisioning a lot of
things that prevent you going forwards
because you have to try and get to a
three-year scope that's relatively fixed
now scientists row thix I allow you to
take all of that and put it to this site
and what you're left with is an
environment where you can deploy it the
size you are now and grew at the speed
you want to grow at no one's done that
before right and that unlocks huge
amounts of potential in your SCP
environment as you grow and you want to
change so couple with that a couple of
things on this graph a conversation so
first of all right now there's the four
terabyte Hana instance the ultimate 160
it's available to our customers also
available in Scylla
that's being available to students
really well this box here is really
interesting the seven terabyte Hana
server that is the obtain server so
that's the first cascade leak server in
the cloud that's the first op teen
memory server in the cloud it's an
amazing box
ASEP published so in statistics were
that that Hana server boots 12 times
faster than any Hana server that's come
before
right uptime matters in this world
especially an SCP right if your entire
business if your retail stores a few
factories if your manufacturing plants
whatever they are if the requiring see
b2b online
uptime matters and that server boots 12
things faster when you have to patch it
and restart it that's a really big deal
infirm we haven't published a
performance for it yet but it's the
first cascade Lake server in the cloud
right we're making huge investments to
get to be the highest performing the
most reliable environment we can get it
to be in order to deliver that that
outcome to you as a customer likewise
the 12 and the 18 are in engineering to
be available next year and again
available on 30 second provisioning
globally so this is not I tell you I
need an 18 terabytes server in for
production and one for a high
availability and one for QA and one for
tests and I pay upfront for them and
they get delivered to me in 12 weeks and
I'm stuck with newer servers for the
next three years
all of this fleet is available at 30
second provisioning globally that
ability to just click on a button the
start server and run it unlocks a huge
amount of potential in a CPU world that
we've never seen before so that on its
own is is interesting but we're not
stopping there the other part I'll give
you is a Google tool called live
migration so again if uptime matters to
you then what's the what's the best we
can do and keep in SUV servers up as
long as possible so one of the
challenges is patching right so earlier
in the year obviously there was another
round of Intel patchi's that came out
for security every other provider on the
planet when that press release went out
on a Tuesday informed all of their
customers that they had 72 hours to take
an unscheduled outage and patch the
systems now in the world of SCP that's
not a simple task right yeah it's not
just shutting down a single server
patching and bringing it back again you
have you know giant clusters and
environments of service that are all
interconnected where they all have to be
shut down and they all have to be
patched and they all have to be
restarted and you can lose hours and
hours of work and it's not insignificant
amounts of money we had a customer we
talked to recently here a ten billion
dollar manufacturer and the answer is
the servers can't ordinary the mate the
manufacturing plants can't run if the
servers are not online from se P
so literally the point where you get a
patch-through that says when you have to
patch this within the next 72 hours
you're not going to take an unscheduled
outage which is gonna result in three or
four hours of downtime where the entire
company has to shut down while it's
being patched in this case ten billion
dollar a year manufacturer it's a
million dollars an hour an unscheduled
is gonna cost them four million dollars
straight away so there has to be a
better way right there has to be a way
to solve this problem and Google has a
way to solve that problem we have a tool
called live migration again all of our
servers are VMs what happens ultimately
is the point where a patch is released
you don't have to shut down your servers
you don't have to do anything at all if
you leave a flag on in the VM it says
Google is allowed to patch them what
happens is we will create a second
parallel server to the same
configuration of the first will sync
that it will pre patch it with the
patches that required will sync a server
across while it still runs and will
transition you to the patch server while
the systems are fully operational this
is zero downtime and and so again you go
back to that customer that's four
million dollars saved every time there's
a patch that's a huge amount of money we
we've currently run over 3,000 SAV
systems of Google cloud every single one
of them on the last round of patching
went through this process no issues just
do the math on the amount of money we
saved our customers that round and the
murder disruption we took out of the
world unique to Google cloud right and
it's a really really big deal again it
also it's a really big deal now in terms
of what it can save you it's a much
bigger deal as a representation of the
engineering work we're doing to not just
be another place to run SCP but to be a
better place to run a CP couple with
that well let's come back to the theme
of do I really know what the future
looks like right do I really know what I
need so again at this point pretty much
all everyone else in this marketplace is
currently requiring you to contract the
specific sizes of servers so you come in
and say look I need you know I think
three years from now I'm going to need a
12 terabytes server then you have to
procure right now a 12 terabytes server
so if in the meantime you need six to
terabyte servers to get
to the 12 terabytes server you've got a
contract for all of that fundamentally
there's ways of writing that but
generally you're gonna contact for more
than you need and you're locked into
what you give what Google Cloud does is
different because that all VM base
because we engineer our own servers you
don't have to commit to specific sizes
you commit to a capacity and that's what
you're looking at here some point I
really do need to get a shot of the GUI
and so the command line but if your
command line base show like this because
it's a command line where what we're
doing is we're committing to 15,000 3
and 16 gigabytes of Hana memory inside
your at West 3 once you've committed to
that we'll bill you for it monthly as
you consume it and use it however you
can configure it however you want it to
be configured so let's say you need each
12 terabytes as an example right you can
start with 12 ones you can move to you
know six ones and three twos you can
move to three four you can configure it
however you want to configure that as
you go and as your project changes right
never been done before but what it does
is it unlocks you from that that false
challenge you've had in the past of
having to know what size should be three
years and you can all the risk now you
have the absolute flexibility to
configure and move your your commitments
as you need them in order to deliver
against a world that's very hard to
predict and again that's a huge risk
that you takes an s-u-v customer that
you no longer have to take we will carry
that for you we'll help you manage that
risk really really big deal and same we
gave a lot of conversation for instance
with retailers as an example where you
know they have six eight busy weeks in a
year and so right now what they have to
do is commit the hardware they're going
to need for a single hour three years
from now whereas instead they can commit
to what they need every day to run and
then you can actually just buy the
excess capacity that they need for those
six weeks every year right so vastly
more efficient way to run STP is a
vastly more cost effective way to RSVP
and it unlocks huge potential right
again we talked about this earlier with
the SUV cloud platform scenario but you
know if you need a copy of production
you need a copy of QA in order to run a
test you don't have to have a box laying
around to do that
that you don't run you just snap up a
copy in 30 seconds consume it from your
commit if you have availability if you
don't you pay for it by the second it's
there it works it runs and then when
you're done with it drop it again
flexibility it's never been a cheat
before and it will change our SCP is run
and however you know it's new to the
market and it will take time for people
to understand it but once they
understand it and I think you see for a
metro customers are starting to
understand that it will make a huge
difference right it will change how a CP
is run but that's never enough right I
said before I was a customer this is not
enough just to have you know hardware
available on demand and everything else
you better be able to do more right
generally there are greater s fors is
fine but generally you always want to
have a better business outcome not just
a technical upgrade achieved
so again goo stepping in here in order
to try and help you get to a better
business outcome so just one example of
that I'll give you a couple but one
example of that is as to be Hana with
bigquery so March 20th of this year we
announced integration with Hana and
bigquery really big deal so inside Hana
mo sofa Lucia you don't know what
bigquery is if you're SCP customers
you're not aware of Google bigquery is
our data warehousing in the cloud
solution for one of a better answer can
handle petabyte levels of data insane
performance levels so you need a huge
amounts of data and put it in bigquery
and do analysis so that's great
however you want to put it to practical
use case so again without resorting
always to retail examples right now we
have a very very large retailer who's a
customer of ICP with Hana and a customer
of Google with bigquery so there should
be data is is streaming in live from the
the retail stores inside Hana all the
other data that they have is sitting
inside Google bigquery
what we released is the smart data
access connector technically what ICP
released is a smart data access
connector for for a bigquery when you
log into SCB Hana you can see the data
model for SP Hana and you can see the
data model for Google bigquery you can
join both datasets together in a query
and execute a query directly in real
time and get a real-time result back
from both of those analysis tools so
incredibly simple for the end user to
work with but what it does is unlocks
tremendous opportunities here so one
more example in the retail space but we
will load cloud for marketing data into
Google bigquery for you so anonymize
data sets that have you're currently
running advertising campaigns given
bigquery inside SCB hana we have
real-time imagery in the stores and at
the simplest level we can join both
together and come back and say hey you
know you're advertising product in this
region that you don't actually have
available the retail store we think you
should move to a different advertising
strategy that's a simple example as a
more complicated example we have a
retailer recently who got a stage and
talked about how we've done some
incredibly cool work for them where
we're actually scanning fashion images
in magazines and from other sources
determining colors and styles that they
can see that the image analysis tools
can see in the magazine and then going
back to STP and joining that date up in
their CP and saying what do we have at
the retail store that's in this color
palette that's in the style match
because these are things that we believe
people will come in and buy right and
that's where we should promote that's
what we should maintain pricing on huge
opportunities here from being able to
join the SVP tooling with the need of
photo and the Google Cloud has and the
data sets that Google Cloud has in order
to get to a better result and again that
sort of value here this isn't just hey
here's another place to run STP in the
cloud this is how do we deliver
something much more to you how do we
help you get much more value from your
SCP asset and and get to the business
result in the business outcome you want
to get to lastly one of my favorite
things robotics so I take it Barcelona
and take it Las Vegas we had one of
these things on the floor it's a mirror
lifter shifter so we don't own mirror
it's a private company we it's
independent of us you say well what we
do is we attempt to make mere better and
better for our customers so contained
within the the mere robot there's a
communications package that talks back
to Google code so whereas right now you
may want to automate your warehousing as
example you if you may want to automate
part of your distribution network and
you want to have the robotics that's
hard right by the time you pick a
robotics provider you buy the networking
you wear it all up you're trying to
integrate that back to SCP to get
maximum efficiency that is a huge
consulting project right and a lot of
technical work with networking you never
else what with a cloud package from
Google what it will do basically as a
mirror will automatically connect to
Google cloud and what we're working on
is basically that inside a CBS or Hana
you register the robots that you have
they automatically connect across and
then all you do is issue a Goods
movement inside s or Hana and the robot
will automatically dispatch yourself off
grab the shelving or grab the package
that you want and bring it back to the
person that you need at your packing
station to do the packing right that's
far beyond again just running SCP on
someone else's servers right this is
really working towards the future right
we all understand the robotics are
coming to be able to do it that easily
and to be able to improve your business
at that level of efficiency is something
that makes us radically different right
and again that's part of the work we're
doing with SCP to deliver you know
something far beyond just the same SCP
running somewhere else so that bit
school right being able to run SCP or
integrate your robotic package back to
SCP and have it go grab things for you
is cool let's go one more however this
is Google we don't do things small so
embedded in the robot is a lance package
as it drives around your distribution
center it can read the shelves it can
see what's on them it can identify
what's there what you're seeing this the
graphic comes around here is it will
identify boxes they're sitting on the
shelf
and then I'll identify individual boxes
and they can read barcodes and it can be
text and they can tell you how much
inventory there is in any given location
and it could communicate that back to
SCP just picture that world you have a
set of robots you drop in your
distribution center they start to drive
themselves around the map of the
distribution center themselves they
identify everything yes and say that
distribution center they communicated
back to SCP and from their forwards you
have constantly running live updated
imagery that's sitting in your
distribution center and that's just one
small use case but it's an incredible
jump forwards and and just a
representation of the sort of things
we're working on with SCP to give you
something that's just vastly more than
anyone's attempt to do before or
achieved at this level so thanks for
your time
that's a very short summary
you weren't aware I can go on for a long
time but listen will happily come visit
you and go on for a long time about all
the things we're doing differently
that's just a really small snapshot of
what we're doing stay tuned for the life
journey we'll be back in less than a
minute to answer some of the questions
you submitted
welcome back we're still taking
questions in the Q&A chat but we'd say
take a couple out here just answer the
wife Isabelle rejoins me thank you one
more time so quickly question number one
how do you bridge from the work that he
was doing with a BA has an example into
the cloud right that is exactly a
fundamental step of the journey for our
customers from on-premise applications
into the cloud because they have huge
investments in their on-premise systems
that they've built over decades and now
they want to have a move into the cloud
at their own pace so that is why they
can utilize sa P cloud platform with all
of the latest technologies by infusing
those technologies into the core and for
example above developers which are a
very special species and I know a lot of
customers found that very funny when we
announced that above is not also
available in the cloud they can transfer
that skill set to develop on s ap cloud
platform utilizing those technologies
and help those developers really on
their journey into the cloud securing
the investments while at the same time
of course they have the choice to
develop on cloud platform in any
language so it's a it's a whole new
world to recruit also and leverage
different development skill sets in the
cloud I'm chögyam back laughter here
because I started out as an app
developer so so after the cameras hola
philosophy wedding species exactly you
think secondly our second question the
communities we're starting with Davin
tasks productions a bigger challenge
what are you doing to make production
deployments easier I guess that one's
mine
good question I mean a lot in this space
we see customers who it's relatively
easy to pull your credit card them y'all
buy a little dead box and play with it
and then move tests across the solar
scenario production clearly is a much
better challenger in security and
networking and performance and all the
stuff that comes with a key focus force
right if you I think if we if all any of
us getting is Devin testing customers to
actually move production we need we
don't make the final move a couple of
key things I would highlight for you one
of which is automatic configuration
tremendous number of customers we talk
to right now
frankly have a production server don't
have a che don't FDR and run a huge risk
in our world here that's the source of
this hard to configure as a DBA
networking to you you might configure
that three four times in your lifetime
it's really easy to do wrong and then
have huge problems right so one of those
examples really quickly is we have
completely automated provisioning for
the VM so when you provision your SUV
system in you don't just say hey I want
an SUV system and I want an aje and I
wanted ER and I'm gonna wipe all the
network ports so I'm gonna manage all of
the configuration on replicas completely
automated provision click a primary site
and eg say a DRS a completely automated
provisioning which allows us to get you
know with confidence get the raw out of
production workloads a Google Cloud the
other one I'll add quickly is we known
stats
techid Vegas is where the first provider
to back in integration incredibly cool
if you're backing up your SDP
environments for production purposes
instead of what currently hammers where
you take a dish snapshot and you didn't
have to copy up to some other stories
you maybe try and replicate at other
places around the world where are you
responsible for copy and files and
hoping they don't get corrupted and
everything along the way basically back
in backs up a blob storage of your Hana
instance you can replicate it multiple
places around the world automatically
use a Google cloud and then we can
recover that back into a fully
functioning copy of your system in event
of an outage or some sort of happened in
typically in under an hour all right
that sort of stuff allows us to again
the comparison isn't just can I run what
I have in the cloud the commercial is
wait if I have fully automated
provisioning avicii I have dr i have
back of innovation I have all of that
stuff I have a provably better
environment right and we and so you know
we we invested a lot of different levels
we've talked about this already from all
the way up in the I am l22 down at the
the straight operation all of it has
that purpose of making this you know the
best place you could possibly run a CP
and and dealing with real problems with
real customers have this one once again
thanks to the time I think we're maybe
past time basically signals like it but
anyway look that's all for today really
appreciate you spending the time with us
and participating in the webinar
separately just a couple of highlights
for you again if you want more
information about Google Cloud
come to ICP /sepb intelligent prize is a
sepm / intelligent - enterprise if you
want more information on Metro there's a
short link here that I'm not even going
to try to reach but you can click on and
or type in and and learn more about
natural really appreciate your time
we'll be back with another conversation
with SUV soon in the meantime please
tune in next Tuesday for the next
corridor layer session thank you for
watching
[Music]